representing the work has been done baby
is thanks for coming on this very cold
Friday morning - so the PDI project is a
project that focused on embodied agents
and granted language learning the new
API comes from vishwas long-standing
vision of having an AI agent that learns
like a baby as something he's been
thinking about for a long time as far
back as the original curriculum learning
fever thousand nine probably before that
as well
the long-term goal of the project is
have some kind of person for his
assistance or maybe like a household
robots that you can talk to wedding
bands to and that you can also teach
using a limited amount of dentistry is
presumably if you have some kind of
personal assistance you will need to
teach it you guys that it doesn't know
about about here the specifics of your
environment obviously if you want to be
able to teach a robot say by
demonstration the biggest constraint
that we have is the amount of data that
a human being can file so how many times
for example will be willing to to try to
show a robot and which may be 10 times
maybe 29 but probably not thousand and
right now we're very very perfect hello
John McCartney is credited for having
creating determine AI back in 1955 and
at the beginning of the a I feel people
were very excited he thought that we
were very close to having artificial
intelligence that can understand natural
language there was just a matter of
programming the right logical reasoning
rules and and programming the common
sense intermission and he thought that
this was a matter of just like
inputting the right facts and
basically ventilates our human knowledge
of the world into life programming code
and kind of like the the pinnacle the
excitement was about the time that when
the graduate his PhD teases they did
this shrewd new project the Scrat was
kind of a simulated world where you
could type natural language commands and
tell it blocks and also ask it questions
and it'll answer he just got people
really excited that if we could just
scale this approach we would be able to
have robots that can understand natural
language and village of the world I have
you seen this this didn't really pan out
the researchers I am and of
over-promised and under-delivered and
this led to famous AI winter obviously
have the province of end-to-end language
learning which eat neural networks I
think some inferences Brook Drumm for
example by a white light and the promise
of end to end language learning is that
with very little engineering each day we
just reinforcement learning we between
an agent to understand any kind of
language this from from raw sensory
inputs this is very seductive an idea
what's the cabbage well the catch is
that for this work we needed about two
million reinforcement learning episodes
learn what's actually in fact very vey
simple language probably even simpler
than the event
vinaigrettes T so there's a question
about eel ability here like could you
actually scale this to more complex
tasks I'm not sure and obviously if we
wanted to have a human teach an agent
about a casting because sometimes make
you're not realistic to simulate like
for example could you program a
dishwashing simulator but usually get
all the details of the physics evolved
into a simulator so we really like to
improve upon this
we've detected a question of the ceiling
there's also been the work on the embody
aggression answering back including 17th
so this environment do you have like a
virtual trading house and you have a
question that the agent has - that's
right and the agent has to navigate in
the house in order to find the
information necessary friends
using reinforcement learning and
fortunately the problem is is extremely
challenging and the results were very
forward cutting was to the idea that
this end-to-end is language learning
approach at least if you do it
naively with a simple model just like
Chow lotsa that the problem doesn't and
similarly in the world of text based
games people have tried to train
reinforcement learning agents to solve
my games so those are kind of like text
base role-playing games for an agent
interacts with the game to something
like natural language and and kind of
the story here is is very similar like
the results so far hard are not very
impressive multi-user dungeon well at
the time we could like remotely connect
into a server with telnet the BB flat
the media at my firm is a platform that
stimulates crowded language learning
which focus on studying tempo efficiency
you might be thinking well there's
already many platforms that that try to
do instruction falling and this sort of
thing I think the baby is leaving up my
apartments unique that they try to have
a more principled approach to power
January for language and how we design
the levels so maybe I you can think of
it as kind of like the clever of
instruction following and the platform
comprises our grid world that's
partially observable language that's
compositional and that natural language
like that tries to be like a subset of
English and there's 19 different levels
or increase in difficulty and we also
have a holistic BOTS that can solve all
the levels so why why did we do it a
grid world why why didn't we know it's
something like a tricky environment like
might have to be doing the design of the
API is carrots intentionally
minimalistic as and we wanted to have a
setup that has enough complexity but we
can study the relevant research
questions for it ideally no more which
is as complex as possible but because
that makes it easier to control although
they're all two factors it's also faster
to modify customize and iterate but it
is like that's that's simpler and I
think that's kind of an argument to be
made that the problem is already
extremely challenging as is so maybe we
don't need the added difficulty of
working with a more complex environments
Wentworth we're struggling to make
progress in the problem area another
reason why we chose to go with leader
grid world because it's very lightweight
and efficient and for running the
experiments that needed for a clear
paper we actually needed about several
thousand with the GPU hours of come to
time and even though it's just a big
load we contracted may take the sum of
similarities to the real world so we
chose to make different well partially
observable and we have some basic
constraints like the agent can't can't
see true true walls so wt9 has 19
different levels of increasing
difficulty that's formal kind of a
curriculum with the goal is to change
agents to master to baby language each
level is basically like a family of
different nations that share a similar
structure so for each for each of these
different levels each one it's kind of a
different opening idea environment and
every episode is is different so every
episode the agent is given an
instruction that has to execute kind of
like an in the same family and we've
attempted to design the levels based on
a principle decomposition based on the
skills that the agent needs to master in
order to match
the BBA is a natural language like it's
meant to be understandable by human and
to be approximately in a subset of
English it has a compositional structure
and it's generated from a context-free
grammar but this is different from other
instruction followed frameworks because
typically what they do is they just use
like a template based approach where you
have like a fixed sentence structure and
you have some holes and you plug in
different words in there and the grammar
is actually very simple and slowly like
about 8 clauses but despite its
simplicity there's more than 10 to the
19 possible discussions and it has
interesting compositional problems the
VI levels like I said make one kind of
progression and this is this is one of
the simplest levels that we have entry
VI is called go to odd and it's the
whole how they can have to do is uh it's
to go to an object so here the little
red triangle is agent they can turn left
rights move forward and the area that
says that's highlighted is is the part
of the world of it the agency salutes
so in this environment already didn't
have to do is to go to an object that
there are no distractors and this level
things he doesn't even involve language
because the instruction is always the
same the atomic mass alert do not get to
that object then if we progress a little
bit we have another level called code to
read law which is the same as go to
option but now there's a distractor
objects the agent has to learn to
navigate around these objects and also
to distinguish the object that he has to
go to words from from those dis factors
that's right so so in this level the
position of the red ball would be
different in the agent would constantly
start in a different vision orientation
with the goal here in
this forces the agency generalize a
little bit better in our environments
that the size of the grid is fixed at
the moment and then yeah so these first
level really involve language then we
have our code go to local which is the
same but this level is kind of the first
level where you need to master language
you need because the instruction tells
you which objects you have to go to and
so the production keeps going like that
eventually we have language that talks
about locations here pick up directly
behind you or you know pick up kuroky on
your left and so on and so on
and then we have some levels that
involve navigating around a maze of tree
by tree roots so this place has the
doors of the agent has to do some amount
of exploration to to find the object
that has to navigate to an instruction
thousand which objects to go to and an
end program while we have some some
levels that involve like a sequence of
instruction that the agent has to
perform and eventually getting to out to
find keys and unlock doors and so on
that's the way it works is the agency's
like seven by seven cells that in front
of it so we structured it that way
because what if we wanted to control
proximate the way the humans you can
only see if the door is open into the
door is closed it that blocks the agents
vision as I was saying earlier the
levels are split up based on that
competitive seas that are required to
solve them we distinguish thirteen
dependencies
so the veins competin see is like being
able to navigate in a tree by tree maze
unlock means you'll probably key to
unlock a door location is like
understanding where it's like in front
of behind you etcetera and so basically
the levels from like a directed acyclic
graph of competitive your cards are
sultan and this culminates in the the
boss level that requires all the
compendious ease to solve and the
possible ISM has instructions like open
the door and pick up the green box then
pick up the green key and put a little
ball next to the gray ball yeah so the
goal the goal with the project or main
goal is people to study sample
efficiency and in order to do this we
wanted to be able to have a simulated
teacher so that we could generate
arbitrary number of demonstrations
basically so we had this idea that we
would train our reinforcement learning
agents to solve the levels and then use
the reinforcement learning agents to
generate demonstrations and then use
these demonstrations are aided by very
personal learning agents to train a
second agent using invitation learning
and who can measure how many
demonstrations does the second agent
needs to master the task physically
unfortunately we ran into two different
issues the first is that reinforcement
learning right now struggles to master
the most difficult PPI levels we can
crack the the simpler ones but but the
boss level will be able to get to around
80% best rings the second one is that
for what we've seen so far our blue
portion of learning agents generalize
fairly poorly in particular they
generate their lies fully to space that
they haven't seen before but if you want
to use a technique like dagger where our
collective agents navigate around the
world and then when it thinks like the
wrong action we want to have an expert
provide the correct action that's
typical to do reinforcement learning
because reinforcement learning will
learn Shipton - ah
the policy for the states that it
typically visits but if you put a
reinforcement planning agent in the
states that it doesn't normally visit as
part of its its lerton policy
it just doesn't know what to do so the
solution that we came up with for this
is basically that we would program a box
using heuristics and kind of classical
AI because because our role is so simple
we figure today it would be possible to
just hard-coded agents that can solve
all our levels to what my percent
success rates and that can suggest
actions at any possible states are
crucially with the most important
feature of the bog is that handles
partial observability so it's it's
important that the Box doesn't does it
just have like complete knowledge of the
environment because because if the if
the body is physically unleashing then
it sees everything that's in the
environment then it will it will
generate demonstrations that are
basically impossible for an agent with
partial observability routes to empty
and to way that the dis Bob works is
that it basically has a stack of sub
goals the reasoning has a stack of sub
poses that is so that it can interrupt
what it's doing and executors of role in
Richard to what it was doing before so
for example if I tell you go to the blue
ball you're going to have to explore the
environments in the hopes of finding the
blue ball and maybe as you're exploring
the environment he finds that there's a
door that you have to go through but
there's an object that's in front of the
door so in order to go through that door
you have to take that object and move it
away so we push like a sub-goal on the
stack that this unlock the door once the
door is unlocked you want to go back to
you were joint before it go to that door
possibly at a different point you find
that the only room that you haven't
explored yet that has a locked door and
so you need to go and find the key
to unlock the door and then so that
pushes a sub-goal on the stack that says
go find the key and once the key is
found that usually comes back it will
probably unlock the door you go back to
trying to explore the rest of the
environments so this button is
relatively simple but as far as we know
it's a it's unique for this kind of
platform so the first question we wanted
to answer is just how difficult are the
PPI levels though we trains we train and
agents that has that kind of vanilla
network with a convolutional neural nets
and it uses film for attention it has to
it has a group of the attention to
instructions as well and an LSD Emperor
memory so we generated unlearning
demonstrations using the box and we
trains we train a different model on
each level for a week and these are the
results that we have so as you can see
we were able to crack all the smaller
levels the levels that are basically
within one room but the harder levels
were not able to quite completely solve
and there's there's kind of a loose
correlation between the number of steps
that David has to perform in the
environment and the success rates are
she's a inverse correlation and how his
sample efficiency what we wanted to do
was to try to measure how many
demonstrations an agent needs to be able
to solve a level to 99% success rates
the reason we chose we put the bar at
99% success is because having having an
agent that can perform something with 40
percent or 80 percent success rate is
probably useless for most apathy so he
really wanted to to measure late mastery
of the level and he also wanted to have
a metric of success that's that that's
easy for people to relate to so I was
reading a paper the other day about mojo
KO walker agent and des paper said that
the agent had her world will reward of
something like fourteen thousand three
97 and when I look at that it means
nothing to me
like if you haven't used this
environments like I don't know how how
far can your agent walk how fast is it
you know those are the questions that I
would like to be able to answer to have
some idea of how effective your device
it is how useful
so we the PD we splits our dataset of
demonstrations into like smaller data
sets in and in different intervals and
we try to to measure how many
demonstrations of agents that's doing
imitation learning needs
to crack these levels to 99 percent and
we also measured how many resource for
learning episodes we need to get to 99
percent here all the numbers are in
thousands and what we can see which we
suspected before is that if you've ever
do any simple levels we need to
surprisingly enlarge a lot of
demonstrations even a very simple level
like go to involvements between like 44
and 62,000 demonstrations and also the
number of demonstrations increases very
quickly as the complexity of a throws up
an in terms of drug imitation learning
versus reinforcement learning we see
that there's maybe like one order of
magnitude difference in terms of the
number of episodes that needed to solve
the task which is a smaller difference
than we had originally then we need we
did their curriculum learning the case
study so basically we pre trained an
agent on a base level and then we try to
train partner train is this agent on a
harder level that you apprised a
superset of the competin C's required to
solve the base level and then we
measured we measure how many
demonstrations were needed to train on
that that second level with the question
we're trying to answer is visiti how
much does this retraining how much
faster can
with pre-training in his way and the
answer is that it's it's not obvious
basically doing trickle of learning
right this is very tricky and it really
works best when you're going from a base
level to a target level that's a strict
superset of the first task and when you
have like a really small increment but
the Wrights pre-training can help a
little bit
they're wrong pre-training doesn't help
it's not always obvious what the right
creature thing is and and one when it
does help it doesn't help by a lot so
less than an order of magnitude
unfortunately yes here for example go to
local is work we have to go to an object
in one room and go to is where you have
to go to an object and amazing tree a
tree grows but you would expect that
glue to local teaches the agents a
little bit about language and about
recognizing the different objects and
that this group you would think that is
pre-training would help in practice in
our setup with with kind of like naive
reinforcement learning aid doesn't help
so much and I would say I would say that
the main problem that I see is that
reinforcement learning your own policies
that are reactive as it you're really
learning to map pixels are observations
to actions and when you when you change
the distribution of your observations it
tends to transfer very poorly unless
those distributions are really really
close the growing problem go to local to
go to dealing with like a visually very
different environment that and so the
pre-training doesn't help at least not
with this method I feel like there has
to be a way to make this work but the
naive approach doesn't work and then
because we're thinking about learning
whether human-in-the-loop we wanted to
do a little experiments with interactive
imitation learning so basically if we
had a teacher that could change the way
the data that it provides to the learner
based on on what the learner is doing
well on could be you get better data
efficiencies that way so the way we did
this is we started with a small training
set of demonstrations and then we
interactively generates new
demonstrations for specifically
permissions on which the agent fails and
we grow the data set by 20% at each step
so the idea is you're feeding the
learner more more demonstrations for the
task that is doing the worst on and the
results that we've got where were again
a little mixed like we found that it
generally helps but not by a lot right
so interaction can help but probably not
enough to really make a difference
so in conclusion data efficiency is
something that really needs work
hundreds of thousands or even millions
of demonstrations are needed all very
simple tasks we've observed also they
take some two times as much data you get
from ninety nine ninety five percent
great success rates to 99 percent and
we're obviously extremely far from the
point where we can put up a human in the
loop we've also found that for
channelization is is really a major
issue which are in the deep
reinforcement learning yeah and and we
hope that that maybe you'll use babyis
for all your efficiency it's it's a
simple domain and it's also very
convenient sandbox that offers some very
challenging tasks despite the fact that
it's so simple
but the fact that it's very simple is
also what makes it appealing because
it's very easy to customize the platform
for your exact research problem oh and
if you do use vbi we hope that that
you're not going to cheat as an the goal
is not to over engineer solutions that
only work in ingred world but the hope
that we have at least is to be able to
have solutions that generalized or
complex and references